today's topic Ricky Gervais I think
everyone's hurt he roasted everybody
there people would say whatever they
want about his speech the golden globes
hired him knowing what he is they've had
him there numerous times so they brought
him in why because he brings in the
views he was the most talked about
person from that whole event that damn
far the only reason people are still
talking about the gluten globes is
because of him so they brought him in
knowing what he is so if you guys are
mad at anyone for that research field
man do you matter the golden globes cuz
they did this on purpose cuz your
outrage feels their marketing scheme
it's like yo that thing was on a Sunday
Mobile B people still talking about the
this thing today broth well I haven't
talked about an award show in like four
or five years I know cuz they're all
boring and bland
nobody wants to see [ __ ] celebrities
jerk each other off move move
dear have this Award Best Supporting
Actor your honor we support you right
now you what are your thoughts on the
monologue I think was good I don't know
just talked about a bunch of things that
people don't want to talk about make it
seem like Hollywood is all nobody keep
going call him a liar on what he said
yeah but it was not funny not funny to
you
I crapped myself up yeah but it wasn't
it was it was it was uncomfortable right
I like that kind of humor when you talk
about oh yeah we all noticed yeah
alright moving on let's just make it
clear everybody know what I'm talking
about
huh yeah all right let's move on as a
matter of fact it was one there was a
part of comedy that I learned being
comfortable when things get awkward III
have to learn about about that on stage
first you're like oh oh it's awkward I
said something that's awkward it's the
truth but it's awkward everybody's oh no
live through it look at everybody and I
be like yeah this part is not funny this
part is the truth hmm
no okay and I actually enjoy that
because he reminds me of mine
one Hollywood publication said that me
hosting would mean that some film stars
would stay away for fear of being made
fun of as if film stars a stay away for
the chance of winning a golden glow'
particular their film company has
already paid for it hey wifey and this
is the hypocrisy who's talking about the
following year everyone was on their
meat - bandwagon meanwhile the year
before you guys were all shucking and
jiving with Harvey
fat come on now
it's like we can't take you guys
seriously and they all knew that's why
we don't take them seriously afterwards
there's a whole bunch of losers like
Jennifer Aniston who got on here and
they started talking about climate and I
was like word you Jennifer Aniston want
to talk about climate change is that it
meanwhile you fly around the world on
your private jet can we just talk about
all these celebrities who won't
insistently shut the up about climate
change meanwhile their co2 emissions are
extremely high though praise Greta Thumb
Berg for not wanting to take a plane
meanwhile you got a whole plane to
yourself to go take a vacation for one
weekend in France and you want to sit up
there lecture everyone else about
climate change so what are you talking
about like that's what Ricky was talking
about when he's like yeah we can't take
you guys seriously you guys want to
shuck and jive all the time in front of
the cameras and virtual signal meanwhile
you guys perpetuate and you guys engage
in for more toxic forms of the very
behavior that you're denouncing just
can't off your soapbox take your award
and shut the [ __ ] up and look someone's
gonna say what a bar you think that
everyone has to be consistent about
their stuff if they want to take up a
cause it's not so much taking up because
it's lecturing other people when you're
doing far worse I'm not saying you're
gonna be that super consistent stuff
like that that's fine but when you go
and you shame people and you lecture
people about the way they live when you
live outlandishly
like if my mom beats my ass for smoking
and I turn
and she smokes crack I'm gonna be like
ma you you I'm not gonna be broken
fingers there's me it's just a bag
yeah Oh Sandra that reminds me you know
what race of people really gets under my
skin
Hollywood because it messes up all the
traffic right for you I'm awesome you
guys are doing internet jokes
I'm opening monologue of an awards I've
read that joke bro my mom knows that so
show biz this thing's gonna be a snooze
but not so fast because you fools are
all about to get roasted your base style
hope you're wearing your flip-flops
Hollywood because we're about to scorch
submerge stand right all right
yeah yeah well if it isn't Spike Lee
yeah mister do the right thing
ah well I'll tell you does the right
thing you as a director lifetime fan
can't wait to see what you do next BAM
fake you towel destroyed all right
Sandra hit up hey Bradley Cooper you are
hot you know what makes me think of you
know those you know those compliment rap
battles if my girl wanted to cheat on me
with you I wouldn't even stop right
scream and holler and excitement for
every time that I see a new caller ID
even drop her off at your house for you
and pretended to be your father I'd beep
and all I mean just the thought of you
being honor it being honor it's not
because you get these awards that you
actually have any insight into these
issues I think you want to lend your
voice to it great but if your voice is
shallow if you have no understanding of
it then you're basically just lending
your voice and you have no idea why so
I'm listening this Brasi like oh my god
shut up
[Music]
would you want to perform for the
audience I mean they're not my peoples I
want to be able to do it like they're
his people no he's from the UK so you
know what I mean
but he's not my like I'm not having been
around you know when you've been around
let's say we make it and we're around
Hollywood you know and we know all these
people I'll be able to host it because I
actually know these people I've met
these people before I've worked with
some of them it would be easier for me
I'm talking about me and I be it'd be
easier for me to do so but it's not
about easy I'm asking do you want to I
would I would want to yeah you wanna
form front that crowd that lame crowd
that goes on to Oh sick yeah I wouldn't
necessarily do comedy with him but I
would host it he's doing a monologue
would you want to do an opening
monologue for that crowd that cause oh
and ah yeah would why why not I like
hosting well you just you criticize the
crowd and their reactions earlier so I'm
asking what I wouldn't know I wouldn't
host it like that I would walk on my way
that's that's pretty much it depends how
you host it like I wouldn't hold it like
Ricky Gervais hosts it and I would meet
mrs. Eko like that I understand that I
do it in my comedy but as a hosting a
gala
I wouldn't necessarily go that route I
would host think another way I would
avoid I would host it my way I would
have to know what that the ins and the
bathrooms of the job is I like hosting I
enjoy hosting a lot so I see me hosting
a gala I am hosting galas so I would see
that I wouldn't mind it's not it's not
the easiest task because because when
you're hosting a gala you have people
that are very you know uptight and stuff
like that but yeah I enjoy that me at
the position that I am right now I'm a
complete outsider from that world so
right now I wouldn't enjoy doing it
because I don't know these people I
can't do inside jokes and I can't roast
them I didn't know it
Epstein I didn't know Weinstein
Weinstein or Polanski Polanski
you know I mean because I'm not around
that word I don't hear the class of
people talking and stuff but being in
that world I be able warm walk on from
the home and do it like him but yeah
about that do it I like that I like the
host I love to host as a matter of fact
work so now that Rick is not there you
guys wanted you guy which is apparently
available that looks like the worst
crowd ever I look at that crowd and I
look at Ricky's [ __ ] miserable face
and I'm like of course he hates it and
then you look at the other people glad
to do it and they looked miserable doing
it doing that corny ass [ __ ] I feel like
if you did it you'd be you'd have to be
corny you'd have no choice because you
don't have the capital like Ricky does
to do what you want so they make you be
corny because they don't just let you do
a free ball sketch unless you a big ass
name yeah so you got to read off a
teleprompter
I'm from you beat you'd have to be corn
I'm an outside I'm an outsider
what you doing okay but yeah you'd have
to be cornered he have mustache
you'd have to be corny though it is what
it is I mean my house galas owls galas
and they let me do what I do
yeah how do you feel when people hear
you at the gallon they're like yo you
talk too much eat shut the [ __ ] up
nobody said that people say all the time
when you have servants all the time no
they said to you but unless you say so
they say they don't say to you but they
say and they say to me like the first
time I've never heard that No you've
never are you talk too much
no because they they won't they won't
they won't they won't come to me and say
hey Lee yeah they won't they won't they
won't say to me so come and say to me
and if the organizers don't have a
problem with it but you know what it's
like it's like remember uh was that
Griffin Eddie Griffin Eddie Griffin and
it's like well he was famous and he was
really talented he would go to the store
he would do like an hour but he was so
famous and good that people will let him
but eventually people got sick of it
mm-hmm but when I could put you in your
case you're probably charismatic enough
there were passes but there's a reason
for why I do that there's a reason why I
take time to talk sometimes I have a
I've ever ever talked that's a thing as
the people don't know what's going on in
the back anything I'm just talking and
talking if we need to head up y'all we
need to meet hurry up we got less son I
know that [ __ ] I go through but if
people are not ready if people or not or
not like they don't know what to do they
don't know what to this and that or the
crowd is dead I'm gonna get the crowd
I'm gonna try to get the crowd so it's a
discussion between me and the organizers
the people whatever the people think
whatever they keep coming back to that
event so I don't really mind
come to me which they don't but you know
what it's like it's like DJ nobody told
them you was poop I have you who else
she would've say but you know how many
people came to you to say is poo poo
yeah a lot of people yeah yeah people
people don't go up and confront me well
about how they feel about anything
that's always that interest I earn more
compliments than that thing on I mean
listen you're not a bad Holmes don't get
me twisted that's it but it like
whenever I will these awkward toes I'm
like a to long like no you just shut we
keep moving and you always get these
prices going because often times these
events like no matter how good the
hostess and you could be great the event
is not fun like when you and I were
together janessa see right just not
gonna put that play but we will you not
went and see you know raising the bar I
was like from what from what it was
already dead for me I was just like
Nittis just give me my price I could go
home that's when he just does the
opening monologue he doesn't host it he
does he open my along any bounces really
yeah I don't watch Golden Globe like
that because how works is he does
opening monologue and after that people
present prizes like me and get it's
nasty yeah if you wanna do an opening
spot that makes a lot of sense to me you
do up in spots mids fruits in spot hair
you don't have to get you don't get
drugged down with the Titanic you get
you come on you do your little sombrero
dance and you fly off with a helicopter
you pay pay yeah yeah so he got that
money but anyways let us know what you
guys think in the comments below do you
guys want preached to host a cultic what
kind of dumbass question is there no
thing well look at this YouTube channel
be like not a chick who's not a chair
cuz you know Ricky got his chance to say
whatever he wants cuz he's such a big
name man invented the office he's
working with a whole bunch of Netflix
deals he's done some amazing stuff as a
director and creator so he has the
capital to be able to be like I'm not
reading off a teleprompter these are my
jokes but it's all this to say we want
to know what your thoughts are leave
your comments below we want to hear